working at the scp foundation might just
be the most exciting job a person can
ask for and by exciting we mean that if
you work as an scp field operative
researcher or mobile task force member
you're much more likely to die a
horrific death on the job than say a
plumber but at least you get the honor
of proudly saying that you're the first
line of defense between the normal world
and the terrifying domain of the
anomalous well unless you're one of the
i.t guys then your work life is likely
as tedious and uneventful as the
computer tech guy working on the geek
squad but nothing is ever normal when it
comes to the scp foundation where even
the person whose job is helping other
staff members reset their email
passwords may run into the supernatural
welcome to the strange and frightening
world of pattern screamers and
specifically scp-000
scp-000 was first discovered completely
on accident by technical researcher
david rosen a man intrinsically
connected to the pattern screamers
lurking on the scp foundation computer
database technical researcher rosen is
actually somewhat of a celebrity around
the foundation's staff due to the fact
that he's so perfectly mediocre at what
he does his job as the glorified i.t guy
at the scp foundation was previously
held by the more qualified researcher
patrick gephardt but rosen was called in
to replace him after gephart
mysteriously disappeared while on the
job since 2012 rosen has been site 19's
user level tech support wizard but the
best thing that can really be said about
his job competency is that he's got a
100 attendance record he seems to live
out of his office which is described as
the filthiest at the whole foundation
every inch of the floor is covered in
old broken computer parts and the air is
stale with dust and the twin odors of
sweat and lithium grease it's a place so
inhospitable that the foundation has
seriously considered bottling the stench
as a kind of chemical deterrent while
technical director rosen isn't good at
his job per se he isn't technically bad
enough at it to justify the time and
resources it would take to replace him
but the worst part about rosen isn't his
performance it's his truly rotten
attitude he's universally described by
his colleagues as being rude grumpy and
combative with patience that's far too
short for someone working in tech
support and while rosen does have a real
fear that the ghost of researcher
gephardt is stalking him he was about to
have his first actual brush with the
supernatural it all started when he
began receiving automated repair tickets
for scp-000
a file that had no reason to exist as
any long-time follower of the scp
foundation will know the universal
designation for the first cluster of
scps to be discovered is
scp-001 there is no
scp-000 it simply doesn't exist and when
rosen first found the file lurking on
the database he found that it was filled
with worthless nonsense the object class
was recorded as null the special
containment procedures read error field
containment underscore procedures does
not exist and the mess of a description
simply read internal system error field
undefined please contact system
administrator over and over again
becoming more mangled and nonsensical
each time technical director rosen who
could never resist an opportunity to
complain decided to leave an angry
administrator's note on the useless file
he claimed that this pile of junk data
was sending out pointless repair tickets
because of its broken syntax clogging up
the system and preventing him from doing
actual work on meaningful files he
assumed that this was all down to the
database not knowing how to react to
having files logged with insufficient
information and he suppressed all future
repair tickets from
scp-000 before declaring the matter over
and done with what the pig-headed
technical director didn't realize was
that he was suppressing a call for help
from an entity trapped in the white
space below the article itself it was a
being born into a pure white world of
absolute nothingness an entity with no
name and no place but it was somehow
capable of thought its panicked inner
monologue is readable in the hidden text
which takes the form of a rambling
stream of consciousness the being first
described coming to life in this empty
world with no memories of where it was
or even how it got there it spent what
could have been years exploring the
empty wasteland occasionally it would
see horrific monsters pop up around it
but only for a split second the entity
continued to wander and little by little
the existential dread mounted as it
realized that it may truly be stuck here
in oblivion forever the entity only had
one word to go on a word repeated by
some of the monsters it encountered
foundation the entity had no idea what
this foundation even was but it grew to
hate and fear it was this foundation the
one that trapped it here the entity had
all the time in the world to speculate
on it eventually the entity found its
voice like any sentient creature in
trouble it began to call for help
eventually screaming just hoping someone
would notice it these pleas likely
translated into the frequent it repair
tickets a coded sos an attempt to show
that everything was not as it appeared
on the scp-000
file perhaps the entity may have found
help if researcher gephardt was still
working at the foundation but instead
its cries fell on the ignorant ears of
technical director rosen it may as well
have been speaking to a brick wall rosen
who had all the investigative zeal of
paul blart mall cop made sure that these
cries would never lead to the entity's
freedom when he suppressed the repair
tickets he had trapped the entity in a
private blank hell forever hating a life
it didn't choose and could never escape
a relentless existential nightmare this
is the gist of your average pattern
screamer pattern screamers are a perfect
example of literally making something
out of nothing they are often a kind of
floating consciousness created from
nothing trapped in pockets of
nothingness between the fabric of
reality driven mad by the purgatory-like
nature of their existence they're less
living entities and more conceptual
constructs pure ideas that just happen
to be self-aware of their own existence
in their private hellish voids the
scp-00 file a file for an anomaly that
doesn't exist and thus had no reason to
exist is a perfect breeding ground for a
patterned screamer but sadly for the
pattern screamer in question technical
director rosen had no idea this isn't
the only time that rosen had run into a
pattern screamer without even knowing
either and just like the first case he
was with no help whatsoever this one
began with scp-s an otherwise empty file
containing only this image director
winters a foundation administrator
wondered why this file even existed
enter technical director rosen filled
with equal parts sarcasm and
insubordination he gave a condescending
reply to director winters saying that
the file was there to test the filing
system and the image was likely just a
placeholder winters never should have
been on the page anyway according to
rosen director winters was annoyed at
rosen's typically rude tone and asked
him to make the purpose of the article
clearer in the article itself in
response rosen did as he was told
filling the article in the most
sarcastic manner possible the whole
thing was essentially a middle finger to
director winters for having the audacity
to even ask rosen signed off with there
finished i certainly hope i have been
clear enough to anyone who may have
accidentally accessed this page through
what i am sure is no fault of their own
so we won't have any more incredibly
competent directors bugging the tech
team about this page and once again
technical researcher rosen was too busy
being a rude unpleasant jerk to notice
he was practically staring another
pattern screamer in the face this
pattern screamer or rather hive of
pattern screamers were trapped even
deeper than the one in scp-000
this one was hidden in the very source
code of scps where a chorus of enraged
voices screamed the following pretend
monster just for a minute pretend you
were the size of an amoeba
dwarfed by even the smallest of bugs
pretend you didn't hold the world in a
glass cage pretend you were the one
being held by something greater than
yourself would you still be laughing at
your triumphs would you still feel pride
in what you were even as pitifully small
as you would be
of course you would because you are
arrogant and stupid if you haven't
guessed yet we
hate you
this pattern screamer is clearly more
aware of its pitiful station in
existence than the zero zero zero
pattern screamer and as a result it's
not so much depressed as it is furious
though at this point you've probably
figured out that even the entities who
have the most casual brushes with
technical researcher rosen end up
getting infuriated but while you may
have gotten the impression that all
pattern screamers are sad little
entities worthy of our sympathy and pity
there's at least one patterned screamer
that's actually incredibly dangerous
this is scp-3930
the ultimate pattern screamer in terms
of both size and effect it's an anomaly
so strange it defies typical containment
classification and it bears a level 5
security lock meaning only those on the
level of the legendary 05 council are
cleared to even know about it its
greatest containment procedure is the
preservation of the very idea that
scp-3930 does not exist because the
alternative has terrifying implications
for all involved
scp-3930 is a one kilometer area in
russia that is filled with non-existence
to even call it a white void would be
inaccurate because it implies the
existence of the color white and the
existence of the concept of a void
nothing exists with an
scp-3930 and anyone who directly
observes 3930 runs the risk of actively
increasing its power that's why special
containment procedures dictate that
anyone who observes 3930 must be forced
to walk into it afterwards which results
in them ceasing to exist they're
destroyed on the deepest level that
anything can be destroyed the very idea
of them ceases to be another reason that
scp-3930 is so special is that because
it's the largest area of nothing in
existence interacting directly with our
reality it's the only place that a huge
number of patterned screamers can be
directly observed by humans they're
described as being like sentient
hallucinations one researcher suggests
that these pattern screamers are created
by the way the psyche shatters when
brought into contact with raw true
nothingness the nothingness acts like a
hateful mirror to our worst thoughts
reflecting them back at us in the forms
of restless screamers regardless of what
they actually are one thing is for sure
coming into direct contact with one of
these screamers is a harrowing
experience in the end it just goes to
show that pattern screamers are a
complex entity they can range from
microscopic to massive from pitiful to
downright terrifying and the sad result
is that in either case nothing can
really be done to stop them it's just as
impossible to stop the nothingness
existing in
scp-3930 as it is to save the entity
trapped in the white spaces of scp-000
maybe the best option is to actually be
more like technical director rosen keep
your head down focus instead on your own
petty worries and bask in the warm bliss
that can only come with having no idea
what you're dealing with the one
downside is that this may make you a
pretty lousy i.t guy now check out
scp-5000y the full story compilation and
scp-001 which is the real zero zero one
for more fascinating mysteries from the
scp foundation